if acceptance speeches have taught us
anything
the number one person most actors want
to please is their mom
but what happens if they're in something
a little too risque
or violent with that in mind here are
the roles that got actors in trouble
with their moms
since 2016's captain america civil war
tom holland has been best known as
spider-man probably the most earnest
and innocent superhero in the mcu but as
much as he's enjoyed playing the iconic
web slinger he's also attempted to
branch out into a broader range of roles
in the 2021 crime drama cherry couldn't
be more of a contrast
much to his mom's horror holland plays
the title character a veteran of the
iraq war
who self-medicates his ptsd with heroin
and ends up robbing banks to fund his
drug habit
during filming the actor sent his mother
a video of an especially grueling scene
in which his character is going through
withdrawal on the floor of a prison cell
as he recalled to esquire biggest
mistake ever
she was furious with me holland realized
a little too late that what his mom
likes about his movies are the parts
that make her go
that's my little boy alas cherry doesn't
have anything like that
holland considers the film the hardest
role of his career and the same can be
said for his mom
luckily she eventually came around as
his parents were able to enjoy it and be
proud of their son
most parents would probably struggle to
watch their kids playing a character who
gets brutally tortured and killed on
screen
but watching them carry out the
torturing and killing themselves can
also provoke
some strong emotions kathy bates has
become a tv legend in recent years
thanks to her american horror story
performances
but before she was torturing enslaved
people in coven or terrifying the
residents of
outpost 3 in apocalypse she played
obsessed fan annie wilkes in the stephen
king
adaptation misery in the movie annie
traps paul sheldon her favorite author
in her house and forces him to write a
new book the way that she wants it to go
even if you've never seen the movie or
read the novel it's based on you
probably know about the most notorious
scene
in which annie breaks paul's ankles with
a sledgehammer
annie is widely considered one of the
greatest movie villains of all time
and bates even won an oscar for her
performance
but her mother wasn't exactly on board
as she revealed on an episode of conan
in 2017 she saw it and she said she
didn't know what all the fuss was about
that she'd actually seen that behavior
while i was growing up
she just thought you were playing
yourself that's exactly right so
mom's what can i tell you oh she used to
hobble
everybody yeah better hide your
sledgehammers next time kathy bates
comes to visit
many zac efron fans were disturbed to
hear that he would be playing serial
killer ted bundy in the 2019
biopic extremely wicked shockingly evil
and vile
the role was quite the departure for the
disney star-turned comedy lead
and during a screening of the film
ephron's mom couldn't get her head
around it either
as the actor recounted to page six i've
never seen my mom like that before
she was so scared she was terrified
ephron's mom's reaction
actually made him curious about bundy
whom he described as
the most notorious evil scumbag killer
of women
efron's mom also had opinions about one
of his more lighthearted roles
in the 2016 comedy sequel neighbors 2
sorority rising his character
coincidentally also named teddy
distracts a party full of sorority girls
with a dance that
ends with him revealing his private
parts although it was actually a
prosthetic prop
a paparazzi picture from the set made
its way to ephron's mom who ended up
telling her son
have some class there are two schools of
thought regarding robert downey jr's
performance in the 2008
satire tropic thunder one says that the
blackface the white actor dawn to play a
white actor who's undergone cosmetic
surgery to darken his skin
is a hilarious commentary on the
ridiculousness of actors who changed
their appearance
for a role the other says that
ultimately downey was still a white
actor in blackface
playing into stereotypes about black men
downey's mom was in the second camp
during a 2020 appearance on the joe
rogan experience podcast
the actor admitted my mother was
horrified as he recalled
she told him i have a bad feeling about
this i was like yeah me too mom
downey also explained his decision to
take the role despite his mother's
warning
as he noted i get to hold up to nature
the insane self-involved hypocrisy of
artists and what they think they're
allowed to do
on occasion he also added it was
impossible to not have it be an
offensive nightmare of a movie and 90
of my black friends are like dude that
was great
jonah hill's filmography doesn't exactly
scream family-friendly
movies like superbad knocked up and get
him to the greek definitely aren't
exactly safe for watching with your mom
but in 2011 he proved that he could
carry a dramatic role
that his parents would have no trouble
watching when he picked up an oscar
nomination for the baseball flick
moneyball
then in 2013 he combined his
oscar-worthy dramatic skills with his
comedy background for the crime epic the
wolf of wall street
in which he played a financial trader
who made hill's previous characters look
like well-behaved kindergartners
the actor struggled to find anything to
like about the goldfish-eating
delinquent
so perhaps it's no surprise that
watching it with his mom wasn't exactly
the best idea
as he recounted on late night with seth
meyers my mom sat next to me at the wolf
of wall street premiere and it's all fun
and games until you pull your dick out
of your pants
she's like alright you know i think i've
got enough of your body of work
lose that part of your body exactly hill
was actually wearing a prosthetic
private part but that didn't exactly
cover up the awkwardness
if you only know aubrey plaza as the
deadpan but surprisingly sincere april
ludgate on parks and recreation
watching her movies might come as a bit
of a shock to you she tends to pick
projects that are of a piece with
april's misanthropic
outsider tendencies but much more
extreme
she played a wannabe time traveler in a
sci-fi comedy safety not guaranteed
a zombie in life after beth a sadistic
nun
in the little hours and an aspiring
influencer
stalker in ingrid goes west she even got
busy with robert de niro in dirty
grandpa
but it was the 2020 psychological
thriller black bear that truly proved to
be too much for plaza's family to bear
in the mind-bending film she plays an
actress on the edge of a breakdown due
to her direct her husband's emotional
abuse
but it wasn't the dark plot that worried
her family so much as the tough
production conditions
when she was interviewed by adam sandler
for interview magazine
she revealed that the shoot was
difficult and involved a lot of nights
as she described it we were living in
these weird cabins in the middle of
nowhere the line started to get blurred
toward the end because we shot it
chronologically
and i started to not really know what
was real or not
i really fell apart afterwards her
family was understandably worried about
her
because she wasn't her typical self her
parents did eventually see the movie
although her mom was apparently
horrified i'm in a very vulnerable
position
in the movie and it's excrucia it's
painful to watch
in 1989 julia roberts was best known for
making moviegoers cry
in her oscar-nominated role as shelby
and still magnolias
soon thereafter she graduated to leading
lady status
by taking the iconic part of sex worker
vivian in 1990s pretty woman
roberts won over audiences and richard
gere's corporate raider edward
with her bathtub karaoke legendary
comeback to a snooty sales assistant
in combination of toughness and
vulnerability but none of that changed
the fact that she was worried about what
her mom would think
as she explained to rolling stone my mom
works for the catholic archdiocese of
atlanta i mean
my mom's boss baptized me hoping to
avoid the inevitable
roberts tried evasive maneuvers by
calling her mom at work and telling her
hi mom i got a job it's a disney movie
i've gotta go
talk to you later pretty women was
released by buena vista pictures
disney's former film distribution studio
so she technically wasn't lying
and hopefully the best lead actress
oscar nomination she eventually got for
the movie helped smooth things over as
well
the 2012 film flight should probably
never be watched by anyone who's ever
felt the tiniest sliver of fear of
flying
it stars denzel washington as pilot whip
whitaker who adverts a plane crash by
rolling the jet
even though he was under the influence
of drugs and alcohol at the time
most of the passengers and crew survive
but not katarina
the flight attendant played by nadine
velazquez
it couldn't have been easy for the
actress's parents to watch their
daughter's character die
but that's not why she waited until a
month before the movie came out
to tell them about it as it turns out
she was more worried about what they
would think of the explicit scene
of katarina and whip spending the night
together as she explained the chicago
tribune i knew they wouldn't have
understood i would have felt guilty
doing it had i told them
when i got the offer so i just waited
until it was done
her parents responses ended up being
what she'd expected
as she recalled my mom was horrified for
about five seconds
and my dad in the background was like no
you didn't
since the scene in question happens
within the first 10 minutes she advised
them to just show up late
a movie about rival ballerinas that
comes out during the holiday season and
stars a harvard graduate might sound on
paper
like a mom friendly choice for a family
trip to the movies
but 2010's black swan is less about the
dancing
and more about the terrifying
psychological toll of a highly
competitive athletic profession
which is why mila kunis's mom was wary
of her daughter's part in the film
the actress lost a significant amount of
weight for the part to the point that
her mom was legitimately worried about
her
as kunis were called to e my mom freaked
out everybody started panicking
she was like you have to promise me this
isn't going to affect you
i was like i promise it won't but it
might take me a little time to be okay
with having a little more fat on me the
experience opened kunis's eyes to the
movie industry's unhealthy concept
of what makes for a good looking body
fortunately though she managed to keep
her promise to her mom
as it took her a mere five days to gain
back the 20 pounds that she'd lost
if you're an actor with parents who are
also actors that doesn't mean they're
going to automatically be happy with all
the roles you choose
as dakota johnson has discovered her
parents are melanie griffith
and don johnson who both have their own
experience with taking their clothes off
on screen but when dakota landed the
coveted lead role
in the fifty shades of grey trilogy her
mom couldn't bring herself to watch
when mother and daughter were on the red
carpet together at the 2015 oscars
abc's lara spencer asked griffith if she
would see 50 shades of grey to which she
replied
i don't think i can yeah i think it
would be strange
dakota said that it was fine that her
mom didn't want to watch it but she
still held out some hope that she would
change her mind
when spencer assured griffith that her
daughter was very good in the movie
griffith said that she didn't need to
watch it to know that to which dakota
responded
all right you don't have to see it
griffith apparently kept her word
at least for a few more years in 2018
dakota told hello magazine that neither
of her parents had seen any of the 50
shades movies
as she explained it's inappropriate for
them but they're okay about it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one